[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Mark Sanchez Fox NFL
analyst and uh he did the 49ers Raiders
game last week on the call for the Rams
at the Seahawks this Sunday on Fox
best defensive lineman you faced was who
oh man
good morning Happy New Year today
um
um
I mean are we talking interior guys or
like specific pass rushers because I
feel like it's Edge if you talk interior
guys you're talking like it's like a
Shaq versus Kobe debate you know where
they're very different like specialize
in their own stuff
um Edge rush but the interior guys
gosh paloti NADA was a monster
he had about a five-year run there where
nobody could touch that dude uh and when
he landed on you it really hurt him
Charles Rogers you know those big guys
Vince Wilfork
um God I remember trying to uh to peel
back and block him because he got free
on like a pitch tossed to Thomas Jones
reversed to either Brad Smith or Stucky
or somebody my rookie year and I peeled
back and here comes Wilfork 75 and boom
I tried to hit him I got the worst
stinger in my arm like my whole arm went
numb and I just remember looking at him
and like I didn't move at all like or he
didn't move at all I was like hitting a
brick ball and he was just like bad
career move
I said yeah you're right you're right
um so I I keep those you know when I
want to say something a little too racy
on um on Fox during the game sometimes
I'll just think to myself and I can hear
Vince wilforks
Edge rushers gosh
uh when um when Matthew who are the two
guys from the Colts when math uh Racine
Mathis
um Dwight Freeney and Robin Robert
Mathis excuse me yeah uh both of those
guys were
were tough man and we had to play him a
couple times but they'd you know
crisscross in the backfield one high one
low so they didn't run into each other
and generally you know they're trying to
just run into me
um
man Suggs was a monster for a little bit
there
um
I'm probably leaving guys out and I'll
feel bad later on but I try not to think
about them
uh you defense them you did the 49ers
Raiders game uh can you see the Raiders
moving on from Derek Carr in the off
season
Oh I thought that was a foregone
conclusion now with the way things
transpired not just the game and the way
sit and played I don't know if that had
anything to do with it
uh but I mean I think
the the ugliest side of this
league is what we saw the other night
with Demar Hamlin and we hope he's okay
it sounds like he's getting better the
second ugliest thing is the way you know
the business side kind of comes out and
the money side and the hey you know when
it comes down to Dollars and cents
that's just the way it's going to work
out
for a guy like Derek Carr
he's been the steadiest piece of that
organization probably for the past
decade and always taking the high road
uh you know always falling on the sword
always protected other people you know
you can tell he's he's emotionally
invested and all in after his press
conferences and stuff he's just he loves
it he loves his team and then for that
kind of breakup to happen
it hurts you know as a quarterback
you're like dang because as soon as you
get dropped into a team you just have
this like pie in the sky dream of I'm
gonna be here forever I'm going to be
the Jets guy like I'm gonna make a name
for myself and and win games with my
guys like for a long time and I'm gonna
retire here and my name's gonna be in
the Ring of Honor and I'm going to the
Hall of Fame and we're going to win
Super Bowl like that's just immediately
what you think
and so it obviously doesn't always work
out like that
um and for Derek Carr the thing he has
going for him is you know I think
whoever gets him he's going to be in a
situation where
kind of like Matt Stafford was kind of
like Kirk Cousins was like they've had
this amazing production with this team
but then people are just like they have
these questions about them like is he
good is he not good and I remember when
Stafford was leaving Detroit people like
yeah I don't know but I don't know if he
can win a Super Bowl I'm like dude are
you kidding me like he's got one of the
best arms I've seen in the last decade
or more
it can easily win a Super Bowl and
that's the way I feel about
their car I feel like he can easily win
a team of Super Bowl with the right team
assembled the right coordinator the
right defense and all that and it's not
like you're having to you know play to a
young rookie who who can't understand
the game or doesn't you know we have to
we have to um hamstring our offense just
to let him function you know it's not
like you're you're trotting out somebody
new this guy's been doing it for a while
so
um I think he's gonna have plenty of
suitors and um but he'll definitely land
on his feet you normally don't move on
unless you know what your plan is like
okay if you move on from him I'm
quitting my job that's it I'm out yeah
crap now what yeah the best time to look
for a job is when you have a job but
exactly right so I don't know what the
Raiders are doing if if they think
there's a real chance that they could
get
Tom Brady or Aaron Rodgers
I mean either one of those guys or I
guess if they want to
you know you gotta understand like the
new head coach the new regime
you gotta impress them and it's up to
them what
what the future holds so
they gotta have something they have to
have some idea whether it's uh you know
try and bring in Tom uh bringing Aaron
bring in you know one of these young
rookies but I don't know about their
draft Capital if they have juice to get
up like that
and and make a move like that or else
they're essentially going to be
hamstrung
almost almost like the Rams right like
we're going all in on Stafford and we'll
sell our soul for that Super Bowl ring
and that's the way that's the way we're
gonna do it the next couple years are
going to be wild but it'll be worth it
and so you know that's one plan the
other plan to draft one of these young
guys surround them with talent and they
make a decision on the young guy while
you have the the cap space because
you're not paying the quarterback get
everybody else around them get the best
guys around the best free agents you
know draft and develop and then pay
everybody else and then make a decision
after year three year four on your
rookie does it matter who the
quarterback is for the 49ers
at this point no
that defense is incredible and I know
they they slipped up a little bit I feel
like that might have been the best thing
that's happened to them
in a while
um I think they they've kind of had
cornerback by committee
at times and you saw in that game
um because of injuries they've had
cornerback on defense by committee uh
but you saw when the when the defensive
line didn't get their sack numbers they
got no sacks and didn't get quite the
pressure because I thought they had a
great game plan I thought the Raiders
came into it with a multiple attack I
compared it to the carnival World Buffet
at the Rio uh Las Vegas uh casino
because we used to go to that Buffet as
a kid I used to thrash that thing but
it's like sushi next to your pancakes
next to your enchiladas and I thought it
was like the coolest thing in the world
wait wait how old are you you're going
to Vegas you're going to a casino how
old are we good we'd go to Lake mean
we'd go to Lake Mead in the summer um on
these like houseboat trips with my
firefighter like basically extended
family my dad's firefighter crew and all
their families but we'd always stop
there on the way in to Lake Mead so I
used to love that place and thought it
was the coolest place in the world uh
but that's what that immediately is what
it reminded me of because the Raiders
especially their opening drive and
everybody's multiple on their opening
script but the Raiders were just like
from one end of the spectrum to the
other it was like screens draws quick
game
um you know quarterback scramble uh toss
sweep inside Zone outside Zone counter
Gap trap runs and so they're basically
giving the 49ers like everything they
could handle on those first couple
drives and it was it was amazing and I
hadn't seen that
maybe all all the tape I'd watch on the
Raiders I was like dang when are they
gonna move the Monte Adams around when
are they gonna get hun Renfro I mean the
guy had like 120 catches a couple years
ago like what happened to him where's he
been uh you know and so when I'd start
breaking down a game or thinking about a
game I think about the team that I've
seen just either highlights or whatever
and
I was like dang where the heck is Waller
been so I just started writing down
questions to myself that I need to
answer in the next few games that I
start watching preparing right so where
the hell is Waller where the hell is
Renfro like where are the these guys
went off a couple years ago their car
had these guys like in position to win
instant uh Cincinnati last year where is
everybody you know so I just thought
that game plan looked a little more like
when they were successful last year and
so back to the 49ers
when they don't get their pressure and
those guys have to cover for a longer
period of time it just makes it harder
right your chances of completing passes
go up your chances of completing deeper
passes go up the more time you have like
those things just make sense right
so
that was the first time somebody's like
really challenged them and the first
time Purdy had to play without Elite
that was the first time he was like
clawing back to try and get in this game
and my only
my only thing I saw from him
that that he's still learning because
he's so young and still trying to figure
it out is like that nail in the coffin
throw that like classic uh whether it's
Stafford or all the great ones like
Brady Manning whatever when it's like
that third down that matters and it's on
or you take a shot on first and second
down and you're getting a little gutsy
as a play car because things are
starting to roll you get a turnover boom
and you want to put a team away nail in
the coffin you know close the
refrigerator the old chicken sayings
like it's over and and knock them out
choke out a team
that's where he's on that's the only
throws he's really like missed to me and
they've all been deep balls they've all
been slightly slightly underthrown where
the DB's like making a play on instead
of it's his guy or nobody going away
catching it walk off run up the tunnel
Forest Camp we're out of here so
I don't know that that was that was my
only fear for a guy like that but that's
something he can develop he's still he's
still learning talking to Mark Sanchez
Fox NFL analyst he'll be on the call
Rams at the Seahawks trying to
understand what's going on with the
commanders they're not going to make the
playoffs Taylor heineke was going to
start against Dallas and then the report
was he went to the coaching staff and
said Sam Howell should get a chance
I mean Taylor Heineken you told them
that yeah mixed reports but that's from
ESPN that he said hey why don't we give
Sam a chance here he hadn't played all
year long
Taylor heinecke is a free agent uh I
mean I didn't I didn't know if this was
akin to sitting on a bowl game here
where you know let Sam play I'm okay
with that or is that just Taylor
heinecke's personality where he's like
I would never want to give somebody a
shot if I didn't have security I would
want to continue to play
well he maybe knows he'd he'd be there
in some capacity I I don't know
um
because he's an excellent guy like
they've given him a chance to start for
a long period of time I don't know
Taylor personally his story is
incredible we called a couple of his
games I've talked to him on just like
this on Zoom a couple times and I've
loved him
but me personally I don't know if if
he's wanting to continue to play in this
league which I'm assuming he is by the
way he plays and the passage he shows
I'm a little shocked by that that's I'd
have a hard time doing it I I you know I
would too I would too absolutely and
that's you know no slight on Sam Howell
but hey dude I'm you know there's only
one of us that gets to play it ain't
like running backs that rotate and
receivers and tight ends and all that
it's a different position and uh
I don't know I mean maybe he maybe he
knows you know I don't know something we
don't know I don't know uh the Hall of
Fame finalists came out how do you
decide on who's a Hall of Famer or not
oh man maybe you're asking the wrong guy
um I do hear a lot of the
and I shouldn't say like older Hall of
Famers but you know
a couple classes ago like what are we
calling Hall of Fame these days like
well do you have a couple Pro bowls
you're a hall of you're a Hall of Famer
like yeah like Dion Dion said that so
but how about this how about you have a
penthouse
first ballot first ballot Hall of Famer
you are in a different area like
something special there so then you know
you don't offend those guys like oh this
guy's in the same Hall of Fame that I'm
in well oh I see what you're saying
change change up the uh like the Tom
Brady grooming situation yeah Tom Brady
Jerry Rice Wing Reggie White you know
that those guys are in that area and
then you could have it and it would be
who who went in last year
I don't even know
uh Tony bacelli went in
is he does he not belong with those
other guys I don't know no no no he's
not at first balance he's not Anthony
Mooney
yeah
yeah
um ambasselli
I think he's Italian
but he's but he's let's see I'm at Munoz
because oh oh he is an FC guy okay
like there's a chance we're related baby
come on surprise you yeah you didn't
have a Tulane shirt on uh today oh dude
wait did I say that
come on
what is that I I just like come on you
lost two different things
but you lost to too late you know what
happened Tulane wanted it
that's the most important game in the
history you know what happened you know
what happened when you feel the pump or
a kick return right there
true there's four things that can happen
right there you let it go out of bounds
laterally you get a great field position
or I don't know how it works in college
if you get better field position than if
it going goes in the end zone but either
way it's a Touchback or a better field
position if you catch the ball and
Advance it okay at least you're not on
your own goal line like in the shadow of
your own goal post
whatever you do do not fair catch that
ball like what what are you doing don't
run a read option on the one yard line
either way that was the first of the
Calamity of errors that but you kept
true Lane
you kept Tulane in the game
uh but then okay so we're there
even after the safety right at least the
kicker pinned him deep like it was a
pretty good kick yes so we're like okay
sack on first down let's go we're good
it was scary there for a second but
we're gonna get out of here you need to
get some two fourth down get some nil
money and buy some defense mark
and maybe we will well you better
why'd you send me down that rabbit hole
man I was having a good day I felt like
I put that behind me
uh
it's a teaching moment mark
yeah
[Laughter]
I'll leave you with this
lions or the Packers
oh
well I think
God on the road in Green Bay
this is going to be so good do we have a
weather report yet
cold oh that's gonna be cold maybe
um
God you I mean you want it so bad for
for uh
Coach Campbell and mark brunell's their
quarterback coach now you know so I'm
like kind of rooting for them but then
to see what Aaron's dealt with all year
and you know just getting pummeled
every game and getting beat last draft
of the game in London we did that game
against the Giants like that was a fun
one and you're just expecting Aaron to
come back and then to like have this
kind of resurgence just make up at the
end of the year man makeup you can't do
that man I know I'm a waffler okay
that's why you you lost your job at ESPN
you waffled no no but don't know and
Velma had no problem doing he just lions
sure and I'm like why he goes don't care
but I need to make a pick and I'm like
bro how do you do that I mean there are
people on the Lions watching this the
families we care about them like he's
like shut up
lions are a better story
yeah they they are Roger's part of this
is his own making here
and that's fine I mean create the
adversity you know whatever Jordan did
it it comes down to the haircut I I I
think it was because he tighten
everything up yes yes I think that's it
yeah I think my brother says the same
time if I get any like stubble oh my god
really fast sorry we drove up to Spring
practice I was a junior in high school
I'm watching Reggie Bush Matt Weiner all
these guys that end up winning the Rose
Bowl uh Orange Bowl out here
and I decided to grow out this little
like Flavor saver when I had nothing
else and I'm in high school my dad pulls
over on the 405. he looks at me in the
rearview mirror and goes
what is that and I said what's what he
goes this what is this like I don't know
I was growing it up
pull over goes into a gas station gets
one of those old school like dick razors
licks his finger boom right here and
just goes one little dude he's like get
that off your face
damn man so
ouch ever since then my brother's you
know my dad like got to keep behind you
ever see Peyton Manning with facial hair
like you know clean cut collared shirt
that whole thing I'm like holy smokes
man you can't do anything
so advice to say I didn't have my
fingernails painted like my man Caleb
uh have fun Rams at the Seahawks that'll
be Sunday on Fox he's Mark Sanchez Mark
great to talk to you as always and uh
hopefully we'll see you uh in Arizona
appreciate it guys thank you